[Musique]
nous allons nous sommes entrés dans une
crise sanitaire jamais vu jamais connue
en france depuis un siècle
cette crise sanitaire va imposer un coup
d'arrêt puissants massifs brutal à notre
économie
une transformation puissant massive et
brutale à nos habitudes collectives de
vie et elle fait courir le risque d'un
impact puissant massif et brutal sur des
structures collectives pas simplement
nationales européennes internationales
qui nous ont toujours accompagné en tout
cas dans notre vie de femme et dans ma
situation est donc sérieuse et je la
prends très au sérieux et par le texte
de loi et les textes de lois que nous
présenterons par l'ensemble des
décisions que nous serons conduits à
prendre
vous aurez l'occasion je crois devoir
que dans le respect le strict respect du
cadre démocratique avec la volonté
d'être toujours soumis à l'exercice du
contrôle parlementaire
nous essaierons de traverser cette crise
comme vous monsieur le président
retailleau exactement pour les mêmes
raisons que vous j'ai confiance
merci beaucoup